inside of us there are two dogs two
wolves
and they're fighting for supremacy so
inside you
one is the initiator and one is the
responder
your whole life you've been feeding and
listening to the initiator
so your initiating wolf is strong
powerful
bulky aggressive because it's been fed
well your whole life
and your responsive dog your responsive
wolf
has not been fed has not been listened
to
and so it's weak and feeble and meek
and and humble and doesn't even stand to
fight so when they too come to fight
inside of you
this this wolf's just gonna eat that
wolf right up and that's what's
happening right now so for all of us
whatever two wolves you're seeing
whether it's your mind and your
intelligence whether it's your
intuition versus what your parents say
whether it's
expectations of society versus your
expectations of yourself like whatever
two wolves you have inside of you
the one that wins is the one you feed
and the ones you
have been feeding now if you're at a
point where you are
and where i am and where all of us are
in different scenarios of our life we're
trying to shift and start feeding the
other one
it's hard because the other one's just
been fed more it's stronger it's able to
push
you it's able to dictate you and this is
where detachment's so key that
detachment doesn't mean that you owe
nothing
detachment means that nothing owns you
and most of us have become
owned by our darker wolves most of us
have become
owned by the self that we don't want so
so that conditioning has been drawn up
the only way to break it is to disrupt
the pattern to really
break that it has to be and this is why
i talk to people about immersive
experiences
like you meditate for 10 minutes a day
on a headspace that's wonderful and i
recommend it
but that's not going to shift this in a
drastic way
you are going to have to go and spend a
week out in joshua tree with the shaman
you are going to have to
take a break islam jerusalem right we
were both in love with jerusalem like
instead of going on a holiday this year
you are going to have to go on a
three-day intensive transformative
retreat
and the reason why i'm saying all these
different things is they all have
different budgets
they're all available in different
countries you don't have to go to india
and live with monks
but you have to do something and it has
to be immersive
because when you get immersed in
something then you're giving something
the power to break your pattern
and i think the challenge is we're
trying to solve it by a little thing
every day which is a good
start to get us going but if you're
really serious about a massive shift in
your life
wherever you're seeing that energy
coming from for the right side the
responsive side yeah
you need to go water that you need to go
feed it you need and you need to go give
it energy and that's what i think
we find that and that's why i think
people struggle they still want to go on
their beach holiday
they they're like no i can't give that
up i need that or
this weekend i still need to go and do
up my house and it's like well no
like just imagine what would happen if
this weekend
you just went on a three-day retreat
that changed your life like imagine if
you just gave
that energy every morning i sit
and i look at my intentions to do
anything so whether there's a new deal
on the table
or there's a speaking gig that i've
invited to do or whatever it may be
and in your life it could be anything
whether you're starting a new business
you're writing a book it may even just
be
an instagram post for whatever it is and
i look at whatever my options are
and i ask myself which ones of these is
a seed
and which ones of these is a weed
because the incredible thing in our
garden is that weeds end up looking like
seeds and can confuse you 100
so so often that thing that's giving you
ego and pride and fame and control and
power
looks like it's amazing right but
actually it's just strangling you 100 so
so every day what i'll do is i'll look
at the garden of my life and i will try
and
unweed my garden so i'll look at
everyone be like why am i doing that and
ask me that why am i doing that if the
answer is not
love compassion empathy growth right
personal push sacrifice service if the
answer is the opposite greed
money power fame if those are my reasons
then i have to take that weed out
i have to pull it out because if i don't
pull it out that weed's gonna keep
growing
right and one day it's gonna be so big
right that i wouldn't have never seen it
our identity should start with
unlearning
everything that we think we know about
ourselves okay how do we unlearn
so the best method of unlearning is this
first and i'm going to get really
strategic and tactical because i think
that people need to
know what to do rather than a concept
the first thing you do is write down
everything you currently are chasing in
your life
make a lot of goals your dreams your
goals your dreams
anything that you're currently chasing
and pursuing okay write them down
you can write down three quran and five
you can write down 10 depending on how
ambitious you are
second line ask yourself what is the
source
of that where did you get that idea did
you get that idea from
a tv show you saw did you get that idea
from your parents did you get that idea
from
your mom and your dad your sister your
cousin did you get that idea
because your friend just got proposed to
on instagram did you get that idea
because your friend just got promoted
did you get that idea because you just
broke up
right or did you get the idea because
you just feel it when you do it that you
feel alive
just give me a specific example that you
had when you were 15
18 was like a goal or accomplishment
that you were chasing
and where it came from absolutely so my
my goal when i was young was to be an
investment banker and when i really
asked myself where did that come from it
came because in my community
small community in london the most
successful person financially was an
investment banker
so i believed you had to be an
investment banker to be successful
right so when i asked myself that
question where does that come from
it comes from society's version of
success not mine
and then the third thing you ask
yourself is well then what is mine
what is coming from inside of me and if
you just do that three-step process
now what you're doing is you're
filtering out the noise and you're
starting to listen to your voice the
thing is you've got a voice inside of
you but
it's quiet it's like it's like jay like
take note of me like lewis like you know
and it's just like trying to get through
and the noise of everyone else's
opinions is so
loud so this way you filter it there's a
thought that i love
which says you know who you are when no
one's watching
like what you do when no one's watching
that's who you are
yeah so we all know when we're alone
whether we choose
meditation or netflix like we know when
we're alone whether we choose
for a lot of people out there whether
they choose reading books and learning
or pornography
right you know when you're alone what
you choose yeah
and and i think that that really helps
you
overcome your ego because when we
reflect on ourselves when no one's
around
that's when we're truly uncovering who
we are one of one of the points
and i'm getting to the ego point but and
i loved what you just said now that if
you sat here and said i have no ego
you can't say that and i agree with the
same for myself if i sat here and said i
had no ego
that would be a complete lie and there's
a beautiful
story of benjamin franklin that he had
his
13 precepts before he died he had 13
qualities that he wanted to attain in
life
before he passed away they included
things like integrity
simplicity honesty virtue etc
so these were his 13 set and at the end
of his life he was asked which one did
you not attain
and he said the 13th one and they said
what was that and he said humility
and and that for me almost means that he
conquered it because you know he was
able to accept
that he didn't conquer you almost like
yeah
yeah yeah i was like this is amazing you
know it's a true story and
13 precepts are great read the book it's
there benjamin franklin's book
and so the reason why i'm sharing that
story
is because the way
you overcome your ego is to recognize
that you're simply a channel or an
instrument when you recognize that
you're an instrument
and whether you believe in the universe
whether you believe in power whether you
just believe in mentorship
you recognize that everything you're
giving
is because someone's given to you and
someone's given to that person
and therefore you're becoming a vessel
an instrument a vehicle for the greatest
powers in the world
and just being a channel for that and
that allows you
to feel two things one thing is you feel
liberated because now it's no longer
your burden
it's not like oh my god i've got to be
the most amazing person in the world
it's not like oh my god it's all on me
you're actually like wow actually yeah i
learned from that teacher and that
teacher and that teacher and that
teacher and now i'm just a vessel for
everything that i've gained
and i'm able to channel channel it and
transfer it to others
so it liberates you from the pressure
and the burden of like
oh my god like everyone's expecting me
to give the best talk of my life
like you know but when you realize that
you're not you're just a channel and
you're just
a transfer mechanism and and the second
part of
the second thing that it does is that it
allows you
whenever your ego gets in the way and
says yeah we're doing well
like i did that i did that you start
recognizing
and you get perspective and gratitude on
the fact that no actually i'm gonna pass
this
whatever good's happening in my life
pass it to my teachers pass it to the
people that shared it with me
because there is no one who is self-made
we talk about self-made millionaires
there is no one that word shouldn't even
exist
yeah because no one none of us are
self-made i'm not self-made
and that's not that's not a it's a cool
term though it's a cool term but it's
definitely not true yeah and it's not
true and it's not a dis like i'm not i'm
not criticizing it this is not like a
slight dig at anyone of course for using
the terminology at
all all i'm saying is just that if we
all truly reflect
and we don't i don't want the anyone
watching to think i have to be self-made
because if you have to be self-made then
you're gonna have to self-fall
too yeah right and everything will be
self-self-self and you'll fall on your
own and you rise on your own
there are some times when i'm with a
social media person who says something
really useful for my roots and there's
someone comes around with roots and they
say something else and
there's a great story actually about
when the prime minister of india modi he
visited facebook
and mark zuckerberg interviewed him at
facebook at the headquarters
and mark zuckerberg told his story he
said that when he was struggling with
the direction of facebook in 2009
he went up to his mentor to ask a
question
now smart zuckerberg's mentor happened
to be steve jobs and so he went up to
steve jobs and he said steve i'm
struggling with the direction of
facebook what do i do
and at that time you know i mean steve
jobs
is steve jobs he could have said
anything and it would have made sense
but
you know he could have said go and meet
a venture capitalist he could have said
go and be an investor he could have said
go and meet a tech company he could have
said
i'll tell you what to do instead he said
i think you need to go to
india and spend some time in an ashram a
monastery in india with monks
he goes when you do that you'll find the
answer of what you want to do
and to me that is exactly why the people
that are most successful in this world
are successful
because they surround themselves with
people who have
differing beliefs and mit did a reset
study on this they found that people who
are more innovative and creative in an
organization
knew people who didn't know each other
so when you know people who all know
each other
you end up with the same answer the same
belief and confirmation bias exists
and you just keep building that echo
chamber whereas if you've got two people
who don't agree and you get a checking
system
then you can trust your gut and go with
what you believe so i think
i try and move away from having people
around me and it's not just yes men
or yes women it's about it's not just
about that it's about building a circle
of people
like you said that want different things
for you
and knowing what they want for you so
when i'm with my mom all my mom cares
about is my health
right my mom does not care how
successful i am how many videos happen
how many people i help even that
and my mom will get over there she's
like how's your health are you taking
care of yourself are you sleeping well
are you eating well like that's my mom
and it's like if i go and i measure
everything most of that that's wrong but
if i know that that's what my mom wants
for me that's beautiful
that's what i get from her and she'll
take care of that and same you know
everyone plays a different role in your
life
don't expect everyone to play the role
you want and don't expect everyone to
play the same role
recognize that everyone's playing their
role in your life and let them
play it that's what makes a good movie
if everyone played the same role in a
movie it'd be boring very boring
if while you're writing your book if
while you're recording your podcast
if you're sitting there going i hope
this is going to be number one
this better be number one i hope i sell
more i hope i sell more copies than this
person who's launching at the same time
because that's the only way
well guess what now the quality of your
output right now
has just dropped because guess what
you're now living 75
in the future and you're 25 right now
and guess what this 25
is gonna define that future goal and
result and your happiness and you're
happy whether you get the result enough
totally
whereas for me when i was writing my
book and of course i want my book to be
a best-selling book
of course i want my podcast to do well
of course we don't do anything
for it to be lost like no one does that
but what i do know
is that when i'm creating when i'm
producing when i'm writing
that's all i'm doing see the truth is
that only two percent
of the world's population can multitask
now the crazy thing is where are those
two percent when two percent when people
hear that they think i'm in that oh i'm
in that two percent like everyone thinks
that they're in there
but most of us are the 98 yeah and the
truth is there is no such thing as
multitasking what it is
is fast switching between two tasks so
the quality is just dropping
because you can actually you cannot do
two things at one time you cannot no one
genuinely can do two things at once i
guess you could maybe like pat your head
and do this and say
yeah yeah you can't do something
productive
at the same time right or creative and
so what i'm saying is that when you're
sitting here going this needs to be
number one you are reducing that things
ability to be number one
because it now doesn't have your full
focus right
so so that's the difference maker that
you can want to be number one there's
nothing wrong with that
but you can't keep comparing what number
one is to someone else's goal too
because everyone's got a different
trajectory
like there are some people that kind of
come in and do really well at one thing
and you're going to do really well at
another
and that's why competition has to first
be in your space
like don't compete in a space that's not
yours
right because now you're just trying to
be someone else again and you get
identity exactly play to your own
element don't try and perform someone
else's expertly
so in modern terminology how would i say
that is
don't waste your time steve jobs don't
waste your time trying to live someone
else's life
you know don't be trapped by dogma focus
in on your own strengths your own
element what you have to offer don't get
lost in trying to become like someone
else or
pretend to be someone else there's a
beautiful
one of my favorite quotes by einstein
and then steve jobs again einstein said
if you judge a fish by its ability to
climb a tree it will spend its whole
life believing that it's stupid
and too many of us are fish trying to
climb a tree
too many of us are monkeys being taught
how to swim too many of us are lions
being taught to live like cats
we're not getting to live in our element
so my second piece of advice is
live in that element that you've
naturally been given
don't try adopt another you know we've
all got a special genius inside of us
it was steve wozniak and steve jobs this
conversation
steve wozniak looked steve wozniak for
those who don't know is the tech guy
behind
apple he practically invented the
technology and the software and
everything
so steve wozniak looked at steve jobs
and he says this is in walter isaacson's
biography of steve jobs steve wozniak
wozniak looks at steve jobs and he says
what do you even do
he said you're not a coder you're not a
designer you're not a marketer and
you're not an engineer
what do you even do imagine challenging
steve jobs
and steve jobs replies he says he says
musicians play their instruments
i play the orchestra that is the most
deep
understanding of one's role in life and
not getting lost in
other people's identities and
perceptions of you steve jobs knew that
he wasn't a marketer he wasn't an
engineer he wasn't a coder
so he hired all of those but he played
the orchestra he brought it all together
and that's when you when you find
confidence in your own role you won't be
envious of anyone else
we were left on the streets for 30 days
to offend for ourselves and to figure it
out just that's it you've got your
clothes that you're wearing
there's no money no food no shelter no
nothing figure it out
and day one i'm like okay like you know
maybe it's a joke
like maybe maybe they're gonna come back
at night and be like no guys you know
so i'm trying to figure out what it is
this is training mode and it's really
interesting what
what your mind and body does so the
first thing your mind and body does when
you have nothing is you have fear
the first thing you feel is fear and
that we can all relate to in life the
first thing you feel
when you all of a sudden feel that your
plan
and you have no nothing organized and
you have no structure and shelter and
all of this stuff that we now rely on
you have fear now the fact that you're
there on your own and you don't have a
phone and you can't just call someone up
and you don't know the city that you're
in
your next thing is survival right fear
leads to survival mode
so you're trying to find food from
everywhere you're trying to hoard it
you're trying to get it from everywhere
you're trying to keep it you're trying
to figure out like how can i get lots of
this so that
i can take care of myself and you start
just
becoming crazy almost and it's funny
because those two
experiences are so similar to what you
see in society today yeah fear
breeds survival mode which breeds greed
and hoarding
and wanting to have abundance lack of
abundance exactly and so you
do that in that scenario for like
remember this is a 30-day experiment
it's crazy so you do that for like the
first week
you do that for the first week where you
just want to find anywhere steel
look etc not steel trying not to steal
but like finding fruits of trees
whatever you're just trying to do
whatever you can finding anywhere to
sleep
and you're offending for yourself it's
all about you
the interesting thing that happens in
week two is that
you recognize that
you recognize that you really want
to when you make a difference in
someone's life they'll help you
so by week two you start recognizing if
i help villages
if i help this old lady if i help this
old man
if i serve the people around me then
they'll give it to me anyway
and we saw people inviting us into their
homes we saw people giving us food we
saw people cooking for us
just because we were helping people wow
and you start to see community you start
to see the value
of collaboration you start to see the
value of energy exchange you start to
learn how your heart and soul
leads to other people giving you their
heart and soul and and you experience
that
now the interesting thing is that goes
on for about two weeks and you think
you've kind of mastered it
right and then the biggest challenge
comes when this is what you're meant to
grow to and this is where you go
beyond feeling good about serving and
getting an exchange and this
is not spoke about as prominent today
because i think we live in a world where
people
aren't self-loved and self-fueled enough
to even consider this
and so we talk a lot about self-love
today which i highly believe in
we talk a lot about non-judgment of
yourself today which i highly believe in
but this principle was beautiful we
recognized by the final week
that actually we were far stronger and
capable than a lot of people on the
planet
a lot of people in the village sorry
that were disabled
that couldn't see that had lost their
eyesight they couldn't speak they
couldn't walk
they'd broken limbs and so by the end of
it we realized that when we served
others and gained
we could actually give to those people
because they didn't have
because they weren't young men like we
were they weren't able men like we were
they weren't skilled like we were
and now so you can even go another one
you could go another level it wasn't
just that you could take yourself you
could go another level
but those three stages of transformation
show us exactly the three stages we need
the first is getting over your greed and
ego the second one is recognizing that
you have value and when you serve others
there's a value exchange
and the third when you're feeling full
and overflowing you can then
overflow to others and so for me
that 30 days like has transformed my
life ever since
because i was able to experience all of
the
experiences we experienced today but in
heightened mode like i didn't know where
i was going to sleep or i was going to
eat
and and when you experience it at that
extreme
and you're able to work it out now in
with you have more perspective you have
more gratitude you have more ability to
navigate
that emotion again and you recognize
that it is an emotion so for me that was
one of the most transformative things
that i've ever done wow that's powerful
yeah and it just really took me on an
internal journey of overcoming fear
overcoming greed and always recognizing
that you can always go
that one step above and recognizing that
you don't
you know as soon as you think you've
figured it out recognize that you
haven't
and that there can be another level and
i think for all of us
that's a great reminder for me that when
i think i have it figured out
that's the biggest reminder of there's
still another level you've got
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days
check the link right here below me or if
you want some tony robbins affirmations
for success check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them continue to believe
and i'll see you there